oh this is going to change now
I'm really pleased to have Rachel tell
us
give us a survey about programs
thank you
um
I've given many talks on program
investigation when the organizer asked
me that they said they should be a
survey and then I saw in the program
it's called a tutorial if it were a
tutorial I didn't I would not need to
make new slides because they told me
it's a survey I'm a new slides so I feel
it's very important to stress underline
it it's a survey
okay
all right so
the general goal of Investigation has
outlined nearly half a century ago by
Defiance Homan is that when we can
efficiently compile a program that may
have lots of knowledge and secrets
inside into an equivalent version which
computes the same function but now it
hides secrets
and this transformation from the clear
program to the what we call the
obfuscated program is what we are after
and we call it an investigator it is a
randomized efficient algorithm we of
course want the two the investigator
program to be exactly the same as the
original program in terms of function
that they compute the same output for
every input
but at the same time we want the opacity
program to be unintelligible well this
is intuitive to think about but what
does it really mean formally
so there's actually quite a bit of a
struggle trying to come arrive at the
right definition I'm going to present
you the path
the first thing we would want when we
intuitively think about the obfuscation
is that I wanted the first day program
to act like a virtual black box that it
turns white box access to a program to
the Black Box access to a program that's
a security definition having the code
reviews no more information than the
input output Behavior
this is rather really really strong but
also very natural and desirable and it's
not worth the case then we can deduce a
lot of nice security properties in
particular the facility program would
hide any secrets that cannot be
efficiently learned from the input
output Behavior
how do we really use this why do we want
it because we can immediately think
about investigating natural programs for
example on software vulnerability
patches that we want we would like to
investigate them so that
attackers will not see the patch and
actually realize what the attack is
where the vulnerability is we might want
two or five skilled programs with
copyright protection information inside
we might want to investigate machine
learning models for privacy or various
reasons
in crypto there's also very natural use
this was originally envisioned by
different helmet is that if I have
program classification then I can
convert any security encryption scheme
into a public encryption scheme for
example we would love to convert AES
into a public encryption scheme or what
we need to do is to hard code the secret
key for the AES inside this obfuscated
program and what the program provides is
the ability to convert input and
Randomness into AES ciphertext
the program itself is going to be the
public key okay if the program really
acts as a virtual black box then having
access to this public key is no
different than uh sort of just seeing
examples of encryptions
and such a program would also be really
useful much more powerful than just
getting basic cryptographic Primitives
it can be used to achieve really
Advanced crypto goals for example we can
enable computation over encrypted data
think about uh how do we do that we can
just give a third-party processor
on an investigator program which
hardcodes the right decryption key
and the program went is given a
ciphertext is going to internally
decrypt using the key and then do the
right computation we would like it to do
finally re-encrypt right with this
program this processor without knowing
the key without knowing what's being
encrypted can just do computation
and this is a concept called fully
homophone encryption extremely powerful
but using program investigation we can
also easily get new functionality for
example I can decide to not re-encrypt
some parts of the output of computation
and just let it out in the clear in that
case it gives a different primitive
called a functional encryption where it
allows to give out outputs for specific
functions
and we can also combine them
okay so this virtual Black Box framework
is really really powerful
how can we formalize it
well how can we say that in the first is
the program looks like the input output
Behavior they're really like completely
different objects but in crypto we have
the language of simulation where we can
require to say there exists an Universal
simulator that is given with as input
some parameter of the program for
example it's size input lens and only
black box access to the function
and it's such a simulator is able to
produce a simulated obesity program
which I we call P hat in a way that is
indistinguishable from the actual
obfusculated program
well if that were the case intuitively
really says the positive program leaks
no more information than whatever the
simulator has and the simulator has only
black box access to the program
great
unfortunately it's quick to see that
this notion is just
wonderful but really impossible in
general because I can't expect the
simulator to learn arbitrary programs
from the input output Behavior there is
a strong harness in learning programs
so this notion is impossible
and we weakness so that it becomes
possible
a first attempt is to say okay
um We're Not Gonna aim for sort of
universal simulation of the obfusculated
program but let's think about more
specific tasks perhaps there is I just
want to fool those attackers which is
trying to learn some predicates about
the original program from the first
grade program
okay perhaps there exists a simulator
that now depends on the Paranormal time
attacker
such that for any program the simulator
is going to simulate the bit of
information the attacker learns using
only
Oracle access
to the Black Box access to the program
now this is a weaker definition
and it still kind of is trying to
capture the spirits that the facility
program acts like a black box right
except that a sort of uh hides less
information
is this possible
unfortunately that the
great work by Baraka oh
shows that this is still in generally
impossible in fact there exists a
certain self-eating programs that cannot
be BBB investigated
okay so our dream is again crashed
then they proposed an even weaker
definition they're kind of abandons this
dream of having only turning white box
access to Black Box access
now it says okay in crypto other than
simulation we have indistinguishability
we're going to only require that if we
started with two programs that are
really functionally identical I mean
other parameters are also the same they
have the same size the same input
Behavior or the same input lens so
basically you count sort of
differentiate them from the Black Box
access
then the faceted program should now
become indistinguishable
to put any paranormal time attackers
so if you think about it what does this
version of security hide
we're kind of saying that it's hiding
any
implementation differences between
implementation of the same function
right so if I started with these two
polynomials as my program that they
really compute the same polynomial but
are implemented it differently than
seeing the opacity program does not tell
me which version it was
yeah
now we can view this
if I see the program in some sense as a
pseudo canonicalizer for programs right
it canonicalizes all the programs that
compute the same function
and use this way it's easy to see that
it's actually easy to achieve if P
equals to MP because all what I need to
do is given the program the first Gator
is going to search for the lexical
graphically first program that
implements the same function and output
that one
amazingly we showed that the community
showed that if P does not equal to MP in
particular MP is not in infinitely often
BPP then IO implies most of the
cryptographic goes down
we want to achieve
and hence this sort of viewed as a
master tool
what we're going to do today is the
three parts yeah
Huawei functions yeah and then there's
another workshow that NP node in
infinitely often BPP and I O implies
model function
okay so we're gonna see three part the
first part is
a mini tutorial on iO from well studied
assumptions and now we're gonna survey
what else is going on part two we're
gonna see how we're gonna go beyond IO
despite the fact that we've abandoned uh
the I the dream of Ideal and the vppo
fasculation and in part series we're
going to see some challenges in
achieving post Quantum security
foreign
that
the community has worked really a lot
trying to get it
the first generation starting from the
great work of Garg at all tried to build
it from this algebraic object to call
the multilingual Maps
and soon after that it just kind of
exploded with different approaches using
multilinear map people also explored no
matter linear map based constructions
using different cryptographic objects or
mass objects
the common theme however the
unsatisfactory points in all these
construction is somewhere in the
construction they're gonna rely on some
heuristic
in the form of some newly conjecture the
hardness assumptions
and
unfortunately also that subsequently
they're having attacks on those new
assumptions or new constructions
so this kind of like goes back to this
repair and attack games that
cryptographers really want to avoid
our goal is to not have those circles of
repair and attacks and just build things
from well-studied assumptions and be
done
and this is indeed what we did with
ayush Jane here and the militia High
unfortunately not here that in two works
we build IO from three assumptions
one is the learning parity with noise
generalized to over larger field FP
usually we talk about this assumption
over F2 but you can naturally generalize
it
the second is the existence of local
prgs so the random generator that can be
computed by ncc0 circuits
finally is this
polynomial stretch exactly will actually
come to this point yeah
the third is bilinear map where we rely
on a fairly standard assumption over by
learning map which is decision linear
assumption
are these assumptions needs to be
self-exponentially hard in the sense
that the advantage of a polynomial time
attacker is sub-exponentially small
these assumptions we consider are well
studied because
they've already kind of arise in the
crypto community in the in the past and
have been used for building crypto tools
that are unrelated to IO at all before
and they all have their connection to
other fields like LPN has the connection
to coding theory prg has the connection
to constraint satisfaction problems in
complexity Theory bilinear Maps has its
connection with algebra and number
Theory
so I want to give you a taste
about how this theorem is proven but
keep in mind that everything is rather
informal okay
and very high level
so let's think about the task of
building IO we were trying to come up
with some sort of encoding
whatever that encoding is of a program
such that giveness encoding if I want to
evaluate a specific input X
there is a way there is some sort of
circuit that I can apply only encoding
with this X in the clear that will
produce me y
right
and why is it difficult because this
problem is rather overwhelming that if I
want you of ask a general circuits
the evaluation procedure to compute the
single X is very very complex right and
in order for program investigation
security to hold I really need to make
sure all the intermediate computation
steps
the results are hidden and I only want
the output of the computation to be
revealed suppose any intermediate
computation steps our value is revealed
this is additional information about the
program
beyond the output
and I don't want that to to be to be
revealed now it's really hard to think
about what kind of encoding is going to
enable me to compute very very very high
degree very complex computation and hide
all the intermediate evaluation outcome
and magically only reveal the final
output
so the basic idea is to say that we're
gonna do some massaging of this
computation so that I turn it into a
different computation that
only an intermediate crucial step of
just degree 2 needs to be hidden and
everything else can be just computed in
the public
as long as this degree two-step is
hidden we can't guarantee that the
program Pi is hidden
uh not uh
beyond that output
why degree too why not degree one why
not decreasing well it's because that in
crypto we have this uh nice object
called bilinear map and they're actually
used
which allows us to compute the degree
two polynomials over secret values okay
so you can encode
inputs used in bilinear map and all this
encoding I can compute a degree 2
polynomial in a completely secure way
and we don't have degree three linear
maps and that's degree is what we're
stuck with and the degree one you can
easily show is insufficient
so you had sat then you could do
anything
no the point is that linear map allows
you to evaluate degree to polynomial on
encoding of Secrets and obtain the
outcome in the clear
FHA will not allow you to obtain the
outcome in the career everything is
encrypted
now how can I
do this right this seems to be really
magical that I used to need to hide
every step in the competition now I just
had this degree too
actually a lot of crypto
has focused on this problem so our first
step is using just standard cryptography
we can convert this computation into
two-step computation where the first
step I called is a high the function
depends on input X which will produce
some intermediate encoding of the
program and from which we can decode to
obtain the outcome y
it's important that this intermediate
encoding as we want really only allows
revealing the output of the program on a
single input and hide all the other
information
and hence it can be sort of or can be
viewed as kind of a special encryption
of the program
well this is actually we know how to do
this all along this is basically the
concept of randomized encoding uh which
can be implemented using double circuits
or randomize the polynomials right
because all what I want is to encode a
program with a single input together
that reveals only the output
so if you don't know about Cabo circuit
just know that this is something quite
standard if you think about that this is
really magical because
I did not really reduce the complexity
of the computation which is impossible
to do from a complex to theoretic point
of view I just I just revealed which
part needs to be hidden
reduced which part needs to be hidden so
you know about garble circuits and I'm
not sure I'm following where they come
in here so like do you like gargle the
circuit and then you give it or you what
what is happening
version of the program and also a double
the input okay think about it that way
yeah okay yes
okay and then we somehow give um like
when we give the opposite obviously the
program we give the give whoever is
evaluating it the ability to obfuscate
inputs on its own yeah okay
okay
so now let's look into this thing that I
claim to be very standard
and right now that if you want to do
this clearly any sort of encryption
there's a special eclipse of Minnesota
the encryption requires Randomness okay
we don't have secrecy if we don't have
randomness
and has I need some kind of
pseudo-random generator to produce
pseudo-random coins in order to produce
the special encryption
also the random generator were familiar
with here we require the crypto version
which is it has
polynomial stretch
and is indistinguishable to random for
all predominal time attackers
the question is well I want the the
hidden part to be as simple as possible
to be so simple that this degree too now
can I even generate still the random
strings in the grid two
unfortunately we've tried on the trial
where she failed we don't have any
candidates that is secure
what the best do we have what we have is
a front complexity Theory there are
those local pseudo-random generators
proposed by godrej around 2000 and
they're basically uh says that the
function is local in the sense every
output bit depends on a constant number
of input bits
and we have candidates where the
locality is just five
and the five is the minimum provably the
minimum
locality five
program can be converted into a degree
five polynomial so this means that I can
compute prg in degree 5 but not in
degree 2.
all right so let's come back
basically we saw that we have randomized
encoding that allows us to drastically
reduce which part we need to hide now I
just need to hide the prg evaluation and
the following that the randomized
encoding
competition
but we don't know how to handle this
kind of computation either because we
can only handle degree 2. so we need
more more simplification so the crucial
step in our work is to show that
if I started with a local competition
I can actually further convert it into a
new computation we're now only a degree
two step needs to be hidden using some
public pre-processing
what is the thing that I have described
more formally let's start with the
function f that is local
constant local we show that assuming
learning parity with noises over larger
fields
we can convert any local function into
what we call degree 2.5 polynomial we
don't call it that I call it that
what is degree 2.5 basically there is
only a degree two part that needs to be
hidden
household there is a way to convert any
input X into two parts q and s
the first part can be just public
because it actually hides the input X
the second part reviews input X hence
must be kept secret
the nice part is that the computation as
I said the computation can never really
I can never reduce the complex of the
computation ever
so the nice part is that we allow the
computation on the public part to have
constant degree in fact they will have
the same degree as the original function
f
and only the computation on the secret
part
has the constraint to have degree 2 only
so this kind of competition can always
be written as a special polynomial which
is quadratic in the secret input and is
Multiplied with coefficients that
depends on the public input and the
coefficient can be computed using
constant degree polynomials from the
public input
additionally I need some succeeding this
property right because this is very easy
to do if my converted input is allowed
to be as long as the output then I can
do it the secret degree which is zero
so what I want is that as we do the
conversion the new input
is still sublinear in the length of the
output
that makes it non-trivial
see I won't really tell you how this
conversion works this is sort of the key
in the in the two papers but I'll tell
you that what is the secret component
that really enabled it which is this
Assumption of learning parity with noise
well this assumption says is given a
secret factor as
multiply the width of public Matrix a
if I just give out s times a it's very
easy to solve for the synchronous
however it starts to become hard if I
correct the output
using just some sparse errors
where the sparsity means that most of
the elements in the error is zero except
for inverse pronomial fraction of the
locations it will be a random element
from zp
so this sort of like a decoding random
linear code
the assumption is that with this
corrupted output
it will look to the random
and if you think about this basically
looks the same as the learning with
error assumption except that the noise
distribution is different why didn't we
actually prefer this version while
learning with error in fact has to show
much more like flexibility enabling
applications
the key point is that learning
imperative with noise will give me some
kind of homorphic encryption for very
limited functions only enable Computing
local functions in a homomorphic way
but local is enough
the nice part is the noise is sparse
meaning that the noise can be compressed
right remember that I want my conversion
to produce compressed input which is a
linear in the lens of the output
and
the compressed errors can always be
expanded back to the full error the
magic is that it can be expanded back in
just 2.2
okay so this part is going to actually
be done inside the degree 2 using
multi-linear map or using bilingual map
this last part about the error is
compressible and can be expanded in
degree 2 is why we use LPN and we don't
know how to do that using LW
okay so now that suppose you buy what I
say that will convert the computation
into this way
how do we connect the dots finally
and that we're gonna think about
we have a program which
the computation is actually not input by
input but I'm just directly producing
the entire truth table this is the
computation I'm going to look at
now after the transformation it says
that I can obtain something which is
sublinear in the output lens which is
sublinear in the lens of the two stable
this information is enough for me to
expand out to the entire truth table
what this exactly give me is a rather
very weak infuscation where it only
comprises the two truth table length
similarly so the first question in fact
has size
exponentially long right
and the very nice sequence of work we
have shown that I always even such
non-trivial time is enough to obtain IO
with full polynomial size
and if your complexity theorist you will
immediately think
we have to use recursion right most
complexity result has recursion
what do we do well we start with the two
to the end size two stable and is the
importance we cut it into tiny pieces
each of it is polynomial size we
compress each of the piece into
sublinear size
now this is a smaller truth table
and I keep compressing until I get
polynomial size of fasculation
so this is the high level picture behind
the functional encryption to i o
transformation and we will actually come
back to this later
all right so this basically concludes my
part one
and next I'm gonna go to the part two
which is beyond IO what can we say still
about i0 and VDB obfuscation remember
that when we started exploring the
concept of program fasculation this is
really the dream version right this is
what one would naturally think and
naturally desire
but the question is why given that we
have IO and we have construction file
why do we still care about ideal
investigation and BBB
right they're impossible in general and
we've shown that IO is sufficient for
most applications who cares
but I want to argue that actually we do
still care we should still care one is
that
the impossibilities
are carefully crafted and under really
just a few examples
enhance Inner Space of all circuits we
have no idea that the majority of the
circuits can be fascated or not
I have no idea maybe half of them can
half of them can't maybe most of them
can maybe most of them can't we don't
know right
[Laughter]
have to be careful to give talk
so I always very powerful in
applications it's mostly powerful for
crypto applications
if you think about the space of all
applications crypto applications is just
a small fraction
applications for most equivalent
application we managed to salvage the
situation using IO but there are still a
few like uh you know
hard nuts left
but for most natural applications if you
think about IO is insufficient and in
fact we would want ideal and BBB
obfuscation I'll come back to talk about
what those natural applications look
like
in addition that ideal and vvv security
is so impossible in general it is really
much stronger than IO
it is also I would argue more natural
and doesn't it say easier to use
enhance
in sometimes I view IO as a tool for
experts
an idea of Association of BBB is a tool
for lesser experts
I wanted to say it's a tool for
non-experts then I felt you're gonna
object so I told you not to say lesser
experts
so
if we think about we wonder one day and
you know broadcast the power of a
program investigation to the industry to
the world Beyond this room then I would
strongly argue we want ideal
investigation and baby meat
what are these natural applications well
these are the natural applications not
with a cryptographer would think about
but the software engineer would think
about lots of us get vulnerability patch
copyright protection machine learning
models let's convert actually convert as
into a public encryption not some
specific program based on injective prgs
using puncture the program technique
I mean it's beautiful I love it but it's
different right you see the difference
for example machine learning models has
not of issue with privacy people have
already shown that from Deep neural
network you can pull out People's Credit
Card you can pull out people's image
that belong to the training set one idea
is can we a fast-gated machine learning
model show that this model is actually
Black Box private
and then hopefully
you know there exists some of us
question
that
a fasca did a learning model is also
going to be private
you think about such applications even
BBB is not clear whether it is
sufficient
right
however do I believe that there exists a
such a investigation that we're making
it private
well depends on your viewpoint
certainly i o seems insufficient for
this kind of applications
I'll talk about it in a second
I just don't know what does it guarantee
like can I can I now surgically modify
the vulnerability patches can I
surgically modify AES to make i o
security proof go through
maybe I can but I maybe I don't want to
even if I can
listen yeah we didn't think IO was going
to be good for anything
because it's not obviously good for this
yeah
I agree with you it might be good for a
lot of things and maybe also all of that
even that I think there is
it is nice if we don't have to
surgically you know transform the
program think about software engineer
trying to investigate programs well we
don't have to think about it baby
[Laughter]
I have to worry too much
so if you are an optimist if you're a
pessimist close your eyes if you're
Optimist you believe in this natural
heuristic what I call is that if I
consider natural applications with
natural security goals then I believe
there exists an investigation that
suffice this is called the natural
heuristic in fact and there are a lot of
Works which shows that when we don't
know how to use IL but we know how to
achieve a cryptographic goal using BBB
or ideal fasculation and subsequently
conjecture that
for those natural programs BBB and idea
of education is achievable and then you
can think about
instantiating the heuristically right
but this is a world view
and this is a nice world view that I
would like us to be believe in you the
question is can I actually have any
justification for this natural heuristic
right I know that this is complementary
to the best possible heuristic that
Shafi and the guy mentioned like came up
with many years ago
the best possible heuristic says that
application if I know
that the recognition investigator test
suffices
then
IO is a good candidate for that the
first grader
it starts with an assumption that
there is in the vascular that suffice
and hence it doesn't say anything about
whether we should believe such a fast
skater exist or not
so how can we approach such a problem
well I already know that
idea of education is impossible in the
play model
what we can show is perhaps it's
possible in some Oracle model
s Daniel and
ayush we show that assuming functional
encryption for circuits which can be
built from well studied assumptions in
fact just predominal time harness of
those assumptions
we can actually achieve ideological
Association in a new model called
pseudorandom Oracle model
which is a variant of the random Oracle
model
and furthermore
we believe that we believe we think it's
reasonable that in natural applications
we can instantiate the pro
with just real world hash functions like
what we do with the random or
culturalistic
so what this theorem is saying is that
if you believe
pseudo-random Oracle Pro heuristic then
we have justification for the natural
heuristic now we believe that we're
living a word where most natural
programs and natural applications have a
valid investigation
[Music]
examples there are examples of
application you cannot instantiate
random Oracle using any real world hash
function but yet we use random Oracle
heuristic we believe that in natural
applications that are not
is
no when you want the obfuscate a program
characterization just like in the random
Oracle heuristic but when you look at an
application
if you see that it is natural you know
it
you see AES is a natural program it's
not a program that people have you know
campus so why don't you publish a
candidate
um a candidate
um public key encryption method based on
AES
because it's not
it's not professional so far
is it your work you're basically saying
okay yeah
okay this part is going to be
controversial I have to do some time
management and then I'm very happy to
talk with you offline but uh let Kyle
can I move on because you need to see
the model right aren't you curious just
it just doesn't understand what you're
saying philosophically why is it
different to instantiate which are as
opposed to instantiate with IO that's
best possible I don't understand
philosophically why it's different from
best possible our top question about it
you would be very happy
engage the same video specification or a
beautiful station in the random work
proposal but the Iranian and the
Homer right they wrote the paper saying
it's impossible so Rachel would show us
some augmentation and to answer your
question quickly tell them afterwards
someone can ask any more questions is
that if you believe that a particular
program can be obfuscated in a very
strong way then best of possible sets
just use IO as a good candidate but do
we believe that a particular program can
be investigated in a strong way suppose
imagine ideally the lower bound the
yellow and the Omer and the rank show
didn't exist that we actually can build
ideal investigation using the random
Oracle then what do you believe you
believe that I mean from the random
Oracle heuristic you give me
justification that natural program can
be investigated in a DVD way
right
so it's different
different parts of the argument all
right so what is this Oracle
this Oracle says that
foreign
it has two kinds of interface one is an
initiative an initiator can choose our
prf also Oracle is parameterized with a
pseudo-random function h
can choose a prf key
send it to the Oracle and say please
create a public handle for this key
the Oracle is going to remember the key
K and map it using some random
permutation or you can also think about
just a list of mappings
to some random public handle
now it returns this public handle to the
initiator
now the initiator can broadcast this
public handle anybody who has the handle
we call this person evaluators
is able to submit the handle and say
please invite and the input X say please
evaluate at input X and Oracle is going
to find out what is the public what is
the private prf key it has remembered
and evaluates the prf function on this
key and this input and return only the
output
okay so this Oracle captures two excess
to the prf function h k star
if
a user knows only the public handle can
only kind of submit evaluation queries
on arbitrary input and obtain the
corresponding output
in this case from this user's
perspective
it just kind of looks like a random
Oracle right
however if a user knows the key code the
initiator
then it does have code access
to this function h of K star
like it knows the code
so clearly the power of the pseudo
random Oracle if we were to achieve
anything beyond the random Oracle
crucially relies on the fact that there
are these two
uh different access
to the function
Daniel looks rather unhappy are you
oh honey
so any application is to really use both
right but here's a weird part which is
we know if the key K ever exists in the
system information theoretically exists
then the output of the prf function with
the key K is more cider random
so how do I use these two things
together
so our general recipe is the initiator
who is going to you can think about as
the fast gator
is going to create a public handle
announce it and then
you can use the key K in a hidden way
can do some can fhg the key can double
circuits with the K hard code inside it
can do functional encryption encrypt the
qk
now
Additionally the attacker can also
always query this attacker you can think
about that the evaluator in the i o word
in the program classification War
you can also ask arbitrary input output
right
how do we at this point because the key
K exists information theoretically I
can't argue that the output is still the
random
um
so what we can do is to use the crypto
it's because the key is never given in
the clear it's giving a hidden way
therefore I can use fhg double circuit
or whatever tool security
to say that to move to a hybrid where
these parts are simulated using just a
few output points
now since the key has disappeared from
The attacker's View
we can now switch the pseudo-random
function to a random function
and this allows me to in this hybrid
world
to just
use the random Oracle with the attacker
so here's how we can use the pro model
which is you can never give out the key
in the clear because then what's the
point
or the prf outputs are going to be
non-seal random but we can use the key
in a hidden way
that in hybrids we're going to remove it
and allow me to use random Oracle in
argument
so also note that either in some hybrid
the key exists and we're not the code
access exists and we're not using the
random Oracle at all or in some hybrid
the key has been removed and we rely we
can rely on random Oracle so these two
things never coexist in the security
proof
how do we instantiate the pro model
which is your shot right the code access
turns into shell evaluation the handle
which is counterintuitive but we're just
gonna give out the code of sha and the
key itself
and any
Oracle evaluation also turns into now an
evaluation of sharp
what's the rationale
if you think about the random Oracle
heuristic it is really saying that given
the code of the hash function
or what the attacker can do
is the input output looks random looks
like the out looks like a random
function this is effectively saying the
hash function acts like a self or fast
gated prf
already in the random Oracle
instantiation
every Oracle call
is going to be replaced with the code of
the hash function anyway
yet we are pretending that the output
looks random
so
morally it doesn't seem like Pro is
asking much more than what the random or
random or culturalistic is already
asking yeah can you interpret this
result as like a completeness result if
we could obviously consider random
function then yes
we can change anything yes
all right so
uh how do we model this
when we want to construct ideal
robustation now in the Oracle word the
investigator has access to the oracle
and then we'll produce an oracle program
and the evaluator to evaluate it needs
to use an oracle right
and now we can really ask for ideal
security which there is this a universal
simulator which given Oracle access to
the program can produce an oracle
program
now
the magic is that
the simulator gets to simulate the
Oracle for the attacker
right and it can simulate the Oracle for
the attacker with access to with
blackbox access to the program
and this is the key for circumventing
the lower bound because it used to be
that the simulator to Wing must learn a
short representation of the program but
now it doesn't need to because it might
potentially just use its Oracle course
to manage to fool the attacker when the
attacker tries to evaluate the function
the value of the program
[Music]
all right so
as you have discussed already that prior
work has already thought about this
question in some sense maybe in a
different format for example we have
results which is a fasculation
bootstrapping aiming and showing that I
just need to obstacle to certain simple
circuits all that are in unc0 or in C1
or tc0 then I will be able to
investigate any polynomial uh size
circuit
are those Oracle o
well there are results showing you just
need to do a feature decryption but you
also need to be able to verify that the
deciphertext that it decrypts is really
the valid homomorphic evaluation outcome
on the fhe of the circuit
or you can ask the Oracle oh to compute
randomized encoding of the circuit for a
particular input using pseudo-random
outputs anyways the fine prints are not
very important but these oracles are
still very complex and in particular it
depends on the circular C our handle
questions after the talk
sorry
all right
well what we would like to have is a
simple Oracle independent of the circuit
that is sufficient for us to to
investigate any circuit
and there we only have the prior
impossibility results basically we said
random Oracle not useful constant degree
multilinear map not useful if you go to
polynomial degree model linear map and
I'm very useful but that also gets very
complex we don't know how to
heuristically instantiate
so now we show it's possible to use Pro
[Music]
I'm not sure I have time to go through
the technical ideas so I'm going to skip
that
uh
foreign
directly to the
since it's a survey I want to
go to the last part which is
the challenge towards post Quantum
security
um the theorems in those works
has three assumptions and one of them
which is the bilinear map is easy to
solve using quantum computations
so this is a grand challenge of how can
we remove this bilinear map or just do
things completely differently based on
assumptions that are post Quantum secure
question for the previous construction
do you need these assumptions
yes the assumption is there exist s the
functional encryption for circuits so
you're just an internal version of these
assumptions
what's the state of the art
distractions which
has been with us
uh where they are not probably secure
from any simple to State assumption and
therefore security is assumed as is
they are based on high degree motive in
their lab or heuristic construction
based on a fine determinant programs or
tensor products
and there has been some attacks on the
first two style of construction
overall that
we should say that some constructions
are broken and some constructions are
not broken
explicitly by attached
there's a generic immunization to apply
any of these instructions
yeah sure
the problem is it
is that
all these works it tries to directly
investigator circuits invent a way to do
that from scratch
I said it's just too complex to analyze
now more recently there has been a line
of work tries to build candidate
constructions that are proven secure
from simple to State assumptions
It Started With The bdgm Works which
they give heuristic construction based
on fhc with leakage and these workers
still don't have any proof yet however
following that there are two Works
formulated concrete assumptions which
will give a post Quantum secure IO
and
more recently that we have worked that
formulated a fully specified assumption
that will imply post Quantum security
so this first of all this middle two
works on is more like a framework of
assumptions where there are unspecified
parameters inside or attacker has some
ability to choose some functions in the
security game whereas this one is fully
specified you know the distribution that
you're looking at and it's
indistinguishability assumption
what we have shown is that there is a
polynomial time attack on the Subspace
flooding assumption and there are
counter examples meaning when you
instantially choosing certain parameters
the unspecified parameters in a special
way then we can attack these these
assumptions
so
overall basically we don't have
um candidates that are
based on simple to see the assumptions
that don't have any nearby attack
the general Paradigm behind the attacks
which is also the difficulty of trying
to construct i o based on learning with
errors is that usually what they do is
that they give out those LW samples
rwe is a very powerful in particular it
would enable fully homophic encryption
so you could imagine that we can do
arbitrary computation however everything
is in an encrypted form
so if you want to learn the output in
the end you need to enable that to
enable that they give out some leakage
about the lwe secrets this is the
leakage hopefully allow you to do
control the decryption right and this is
also the part that creates problem
because when you give out leakage it
automatically translates itself into
leakage on the noise
so all the attacks explore the fact that
you can collect equations over LW noise
in particular there are equations over
the integers
and after you get lots of equations you
can attempt they're not necessarily the
linear equations but you can attempt to
linearize it and then solve for the
noise or you can try to distinguish
using certain statistical tests
it's really open and I think a good
question is to find LW with leakage
assumptions that are sufficient for Io
but with justification for harness at
least against known attacks
certain classes of attacks
right so that's it uh what are the
challenges there are really really lots
of challenges in this space and I think
we need really good new ideas for
example can we have weaker assumptions
forget about post Quantum security
removing any assumption is good or
coming up with different work that uses
different different set of assumptions
security is a big problem
and I think that the near the median
goal is to just get candidate from
simple to say the assumption that don't
have nearby attacks and this
we might not be able to achieve it one
step we will need to allow a little bit
trial of error and there's still with
new assumptions proposed
and recently we have construction of now
I O based on a new assumption which is
called evasive lwe
and a question is can we modify Oneness
you approach from the above this the
other is you approach it from the bottom
this is what we know how to do can we
get bigger classes of circuits for
example can we do evasive circuits can
we do this Subspace hiding circuits
which is very interesting for the post
for the quantum community
efficiency is a big problem I didn't
manage to show you but at least I'll
show you the recursive approach this
recursive approach is never going to be
efficient
however if you think about it that when
we first had prf with the ggm trees
which is very similar to currently the
fe2io recursion
later on
money for example give algebraic
constructions directly for the prf that
are much more efficient than using the
tree structure can we do something
similar here to get rid of this
transformation
beyond the aisle what more can we say
about ideal and the video investigation
I really think that
sometimes that the negative results has
the undesirable effect of completely
damping research from a particular
object and we should really do more on
this because the security is the most
desirable
okay
thank you
[Applause]
a bit over time
but wait until my talk yeah
um you had the three is simple to State
assumptions and then you focus on the
one that's broken by quantum computers
that is why I only care about classical
computers which assumption do you think
is
I have not answered this question
because I am not a crypto analyst and I
have no idea and the answer I will give
you is based on that feeling and
actually this is a good point I do want
to point out
I feel that any removing any assumption
is extremely valuable often times I hire
people from different communities say
different things for example complex
circular systems should be totally fine
with local prgs crypto Community like
less than or copy ideas some people they
prefer the algebraic assumptions and LPN
or they may think that LW is the right
answer well sometimes I feel this kind
of ideas come from popularity rather
than really is based on how hard the
assumptions are right suppose that
anybody who has written a paper based on
lwe believe in LW that clearly has a lot
of votes but
say anything about how hard LW is the
structure may actually be a curse
comparing with LPN right so I think we
want to not confuse these things
together I am not a crypto analysis so I
can't say but I just think that removing
any assumptions group so thank you for
the amazing talk yeah
for the polo for the assumptions panel
which will be today
and during the break you have enough
time to write an email to a quick
analyst and then when you get the answer
okay
[Applause]
foreign